hey guys i'm raul from simply learn and
welcome to the session on the top job
roles in the field of cloud computing in
2020
now let's get started let's have a look
at some cloud computing stats in 2020.
did you know that 90 of companies use
some type of cloud service
that in the united states companies have
spent about 124 billion dollars
in cloud services and the worldwide
public cloud service market
could grow up to 331 billion dollars
by 2022. if you guys didn't realize by
now
cloud computing as a domain is growing
at a really fast rate
and it looks like there's no stopping it
either
let's have a look at some of the skills
required to become a cloud administrator
first off you need experience with
programming languages like c sharpen.net
you'll also need to be experienced with
devops tools like jenkins
docker ansible and chef you'll need to
have an understanding of database
configuration
so that you can take advantage of all
the relevant information
about the hardware and software
components used by the organization
you will also need to have experience
with cloud infrastructure systems
like servers storage network and
visualization software
finally you'll also need to configure
virtual machines vpns and cloud servers
now let's have a look at the salary
offered to cloud administrators
now in the united states the average
salary of a cloud administrator
is approximately 65 000 per annum
similarly in india it's approximately
seven lakh rupees per annum
now let's have a look at some of the
companies hiring for cloud
administrators
we have companies like wipro infosys
accenture
ibm and so on so here i see a comment
which says
i'm a fresher and want to learn about
aws
how can i start so actually any fresher
can make a career in aws
as long as you have interest towards the
subject now
if you are from a non-technical
background you need to put in
a lot more hard work and have a lot of
patience
so i would recommend that before you
take up the aws course you have a look
at the course curriculum
types of aws courses opportunities in
the market for aws certified candidates
and so on
so now let's go to number six cloud
application
developer now a cloud application
developer mainly focuses
on implementing and maintaining an
organization's cloud infrastructure
now they're involved with designing
building creating
analyzing and maintaining cloud systems
now
these individuals are also involved with
ensuring that there's an effective
design of business processes
in the cloud they're also involved with
a number of different tasks
like optimizing efficiency and
performance scaling application
components and security issues
now let's have a look at some of the
skills required to become a cloud
application developer
first off you need to have experience
with database languages
like mysql sql and mongodb then you need
to have experience with programming
languages
like python ruby and perl so that you
can code and create cloud computing
applications
you'll also need to have experience with
linux now this is because
most cloud infrastructures are created
with linux servers
you'll also need to have experience with
cloud service providers like amazon web
services
google cloud platform and microsoft
azure you'll need to have experience
with information security
with the help of certifications you'll
also need to know how to create
microservices
and to create cloud applications now
let's have a look at the salary offered
to a cloud application developer
in the united states it's approximately
seventy thousand dollars per annum
in india the average salary of a cloud
application developer
is approximately eight lakh rupees per
annum now let's have a look at some of
the companies hiring cloud application
developers
you have companies like bosch mcafee zap
and so on
so now let's go to number five cloud
network engineer
a cloud network engineer is responsible
for implementing
supporting maintaining and optimizing
the network hardware
software and communication links of the
organization's cloud infrastructure
he or she basically focuses on
automation and security
while building the cloud infrastructure
enhancing network tooling visibility
and improving productivity now let's
have a look at some of the skills
required to become a cloud network
engineer
first off obviously you need to have
experience with networking
which means a familiarity with the
internet and van communication
technologies
protocols and best practices you need to
have an understanding of cloud security
and how you can design a public cloud
with multiple options
you'll need to have an experience with
data center administration
which basically means an understanding
on infrastructure design
operations and life cycle management and
finally you need to have experience
with cloud computing platforms like
amazon web services
microsoft azure and google cloud
platform next
let's have a look at the salaries
offered to a cloud network engineer
firstly the average salary of a cloud
network engineer in the united states is
approximately
seventy two thousand dollars per annum
in india the average salary of a cloud
network engineer
is approximately four lakh rupees per
annum
now that we're done with this let's have
a look at the companies hiring cloud
network engineers
we have companies like amazon web
services rakuten
cisco and so much more now for number
four
we have cloud automation engineer a
cloud automation engineer focuses on
cloud automation
orchestration and integration he or she
implements
optimizes and supports the cloud
infrastructure and ensures it has high
availability
they also have to increase the cost
effectiveness and availability of the
cloud
now let's have a look at some of the
skills required to become a cloud
automation
engineer first off since the role is
cloud-based
experience with the cloud service
platform like microsoft azure
aws or google cloud platform is an
absolute must
you'll also need to have experience with
programming languages like python and go
that will help you make the process of
automation easier
next experience with devops tools like
chef ansible and puppet are seen as a
huge plus
you'll also need to have an
understanding of docker and containers
experience with databases like
postgresql
and mysql that can handle multiple
workloads would be very useful
and finally you need to have experience
with virtualization
which means you need to know how you can
work with virtual servers
applications storage and networks with
this you can reduce the amount of
resources
required by the organization now let's
have a look at the salary offered to
cloud automation engineers
in the united states the average salary
for cloud automation engineer
is approximately seventy nine thousand
dollars per annum the average salary for
cloud automation engineer in india
is approximately five lakh rupees per
annum now that we're done let's have a
look at some of the companies hiring
cloud automation engineers
we have companies like oracle google
kappa gemini
disney and so on and now to number three
cloud security manager a cloud security
manager
is someone who is responsible for
providing security
for cloud-based digital platforms and
protecting the organization's data
he or she may be involved with creating
new security methods
or to analyze existing ones they may
also have to create cloud-based
applications
performing threat simulations and
providing security recommendations
now let's have a look at some of the
skills required to become a cloud
security manager
first off you need to have experience
with at least one of the popular cloud
service providers
like amazon web services microsoft azure
and gcp
you'll also need to have experience in
programming languages like python
experience with commonly used devops
tools like jenkin
so that you can implement continuous
integration or continuous deployment
models
would be very helpful you'll also need
to be well versed with tcp protocols
and other networking concepts you need
to be well versed with pki
ssl ssh https and so on
experience with web-based analytics and
services would also be very helpful
now let's have a look at the salary
offered to a cloud security manager
in the united states the average salary
of a cloud security manager
is approximately 99 000 per annum
in india the average salary for cloud
security manager is approximately 11
lakh rupees
per random now let's have a look at some
of the companies hiring
cloud security managers we have
companies like deloitte vmware cisco
dell and so on now let's move on to
number two
cloud engineer a cloud engineer is an
individual who is responsible for any
technological duties
that are associated with cloud computing
including design
planning management maintenance and
support they are also involved with
orchestrating and automating cloud-based
platforms
throughout the organization let's have a
look at the skills required to become a
cloud engineer
first off you need to have experience
with at least one of the popular cloud
service providers
like aws microsoft azure or the google
cloud platform
you'll need to have an understanding of
networking concepts
like building and accessing servers
virtual networks and so on
this enables cloud engineers to make
sure that the network is responsive to
the users
next you need to have experience with
virtualization
with virtualization you can reduce how
many hardware units you need
with the help of virtual machines it
also makes resources scalable
and fault tolerant in an organization
experience with the linux operating
system would also be very helpful
considering how 30 of the servers that
powers you are linux based
you'll need to know about apis to design
restful services
experience with devops is also a major
skill to have
since it'll be able to help handle work
dependencies
between the development and operation
teams and finally you need to have
programming experience
with languages like java python c plus
and ruby
next let's have a look at the salary
offered to a cloud engineer
in the united states the average salary
of a cloud engineer is approximately 105
000 per annum the average salary in
india is approximately 5 lakh rupees per
random
now let's have a look at some of the
companies hiring cloud engineers
we have companies like mcafee ibm
jpmorgan
visa and so on now i see a pretty good
question in the chat
how do you become a cloud engineer so to
become a cloud engineer you need to have
experience with the programming language
experience with at least
one cloud service platform which is
amazon web services or microsoft azure
or google cloud platform
the choice is yours and you need to
specialize in a particular service
be it storage networking disaster
recovery and so on
and now for number one cloud architect
a cloud architect is responsible for
managing cloud computing architecture in
an organization
he or she handles everything to do with
front-end platforms
servers storage delivery and networks
now let's have a look at some of the
skills required to become a cloud
architect
first off you need to have knowledge in
programming knowledge about
perl python ruby php java and
net can provide users with the ability
to build deploy and manage applications
quickly
you'll need to know about the basics of
networking since most of the work what
you'll be doing would be web related
knowledge about networking can be really
helpful
knowledge about data storage
fundamentals are also really important
this provides you with the knowledge to
determine which data storage option to
use
and when being experienced with cloud
service platforms is also really
important
platforms like aws google cloud platform
and microsoft azure
are what you are going to be basing most
of your work on experience with them is
pretty important
and finally cloud security this will
help you make sure that your data is
secure and only authorized code is run
and the right people are allowed to run
it now
let's talk about the salary of a cloud
architect the average salary for cloud
architect is approximately 107 000
per annum in india the average salary of
a cloud architect is approximately 16
lakh rupees per annum
and there you go those are the top job
roles in the field of cloud computing
now let's have a look at some of the
companies hiring cloud architects
we have companies like ey weipro huawei
hewlett packard enterprise and so on
with that we've reached the end of this
video
thank you for joining this session don't
forget to subscribe to our channel
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here